Facebook continues to grapple with
bandwidth the backlash this morning over
the political data scandal CEO Mark
Zuckerberg will speak in the next 24
hours about rebuilding trust in a
statement a facebook spokesperson
spokesperson said Mark Cheryl and their
teams are working around the clock to
get all the facts and take the
appropriate action attorneys general in
New York and Massachusetts launched a
joint investigation into how a British
firm got hold of more than 50 million
users personal information Senators in
both parties want Zuckerberg and other
Silicon Valley executives to appear on
Capitol Hill Jessica lessin is the
founder and editor-in-chief of the
technology news website the information
Jessica good morning good morning so
what do you make a Facebook's reaction
here another thing that the company said
was the entire company is outraged we
were deceived is that genuine outraged
or is it sort of were shocked there's
gambling in Kenyan Casablanca well I
think you know Facebook was surprised by
the revelations that Cambridge analytic
I still had this data but that response
is clearly insufficient you know users
don't want to hear that Facebook was
surprised that this data is out there
they want to know what they're doing and
so I think we need to hear from mark we
need to hear from Cheryl and I'm sort of
wondering why we're waiting yeah why
haven't we heard from them it's a very
very complicated issue and you know tech
people like to think about the technical
nuances but I think I'm sure we will
hear something as you guys said and yeah
this is a big moment this is a crisis
unlike one they face it is crisis 101 do
you give them credit for saying listen
we want to get all the facts before we
come out and talk to our people do they
get credit for that you always want the
facts before you talk but there are some
things you can say and I think to have a
meeting yesterday where you're not
present and you know you stick your
lawyer in front of your employees
phrases mean it seems odd to me so but
there's a hashtag trending that says
delete Facebook what do you think they
need to do to win back the confidence of
users it may be a little doubtful right
now
they need to prove that they've really
plugged a lot of the leakiness of this
data and this is a brave new challenge
facing the Internet they're not alone in
having to deal with it but I think until
users really believe that they can use
Facebook without their data getting in
the hands of people who shouldn't have
it they're gonna face a lot of pressure
from users and from regulators and what
about advertisers at what point are they
going to start worrying about whether
advertisers start pulling back so
advertisers are concerned they are
concerned about the trust that Facebook
that Google have with their users over
the last year we've seen some very
prominent ones say that they are pulling
back in some ways so this will make that
worse I think for Facebook the reason
users are skeptical is they're not sure
that Facebook's heart is in it and
there's a quote from a scientist who
worked with Cambridge analytical who
said using users data for profit is
their business model meaning Facebook
vice president of Facebook wrote this is
the opposite of our business model so
which is it somewhere in the middle I
mean I I think it a high level the
business model is absolutely around you
know using users data to sell
advertising you know this incident was a
case of abuse it was a case of where a
third party told Facebook it had deleted
the data and it had it but that's still
Facebook's problem and so that's what
they need says we've been teasing all
morning that you said we've reached a
tipping point in terms of what we can
expect in privacy I believe that's true
I think that you know the internet and
these services are using data in such
aggressive ways that we have to be
really careful as consumers and I think
we'll see from this and what I mean by
the tipping point is I think things will
change
mm-hmm and what I think is gonna happen
is tech companies are gonna close
themselves off a bit I think there are
still ways that third-party apps and
advertisers are using Facebook I don't
think all of that will go away but what
Facebook is probably churning away on
now is closing some of those loopholes
because they just have to all eyes and
ears will be on Mark Zuckerberg on what
he has to say today thank you so much
that's what we appreciate it